catastrophe in Alabama a Democrat won
the deep reds state Senate seat
I personally blame the Russians and Jim
Comey unfortunately Republicans are
drawing terrible conclusions from this
whole experience we will analyze what
conservatives should really take away
from Roy Moore's defeat then a man to
press DiGiacomo and Allie Stuckey joined
the panel of deplorable z' to talk about
a new study which shows that the key to
living a long life is being a stubborn
old Italian woman huge anti-trump bias
at the DOJ and in Bob Muller's
investigation exposed and the real cause
of the literal fires not the weird sex
crime figurative fires that burned down
my city of Los Angeles
I am Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
you know pretty bad news last night bad
news for the Republican majority in the
Senate for the Trump agenda it was a
tough night and I feel that I need to
console myself the way that I can
console myself I can feel a little bit
better I can feel good as good as I did
as a child walking through shopping
malls is to talk about mrs. fields our
sponsor these are it if you're like me
you your favorite part of going to the
mall as a kid was stopping by mrs.
fields now it's probably going to be
your favorite part of Christmas shopping
too it's very hard we're getting a
little close to Christmas now there is
one way that you cannot strike out
buying Christmas presents and it is to
send them those delicious those perfect
chocolate chip cookies that will make
you feel like a kid again
give your friends and family the same
feeling of pure joy with a holiday gift
arrangement from mrs. fields mrs. Fields
Cookies have been around for 40 years
when I did the the on boarding call with
mrs. fields we were talking about my
favorite mrs. Fields Cookies I remember
them from when I was a little boy in
shopping malls you know the whole mall
would smell like mrs. fields and I would
force my parents to go and get me the
sugar cookies those are my favorite mrs.
Fields Cookies a lot of people like the
chocolate chip they have these oatmeal
raisin ones that are unbelievable but
they said well Michael how are you gonna
talk about it well you know it's a real
hard pitch it's a real hard pitch to
convince people to eat delicious
chocolate chip cookies but I think I can
do it I I think I'll be able to get
across the reasons that you might enjoy
tasty chocolate chip cookies they are
they are really wonderful and there's an
exclusive deal for my listeners if you
go to mrs. Fields dot-com and you click
on the microphone in the upper right
hand corner and you enter in the code
kofi fey COV f e fe want your cookie
type in cofee fey co v fe fe you will
save 20% on any mrs. Fields product
that's pretty good as 1/5 off 20 20 %
that includes their best-selling piece
love and cookies ten at which if you use
my code becomes the peace love cookies
and coffee fa 10 it comes with holiday
favorites like nibblers
sighs cookies brownie bites and much
much more so go to mrs. fields calm
click on the microphone type in what
what do you type in you know Co V Fe Fe
cough FA you'll get 20% off of any
product at mrs. fields dot-com okay
we're feeling too good we're starting
out this terrible terrible day feeling
too good so let's get back into reality
a rough night for Republicans take it
away mainstream media that breaking news
coming out of Alabama this morning a
stunning end to the race for Senate as
Doug Jones claims victory while his
opponent Roy Moore says things are far
from over Senate race against Republican
Roy Moore this is a seismic Democratic
victory in a deeply red state we have
team coverage with reporters in both
camps tonight Democrat Doug Jones wins a
stunning victory in the Senate election
in Alabama and tonight I'm Don Lemon
thank you for staying up with us an
incredible victory for the Democratic
candidate in one of the reddest of red
states I want you to listen to this
joyful reaction at Doug Jones
headquarters seismic stunning miraculous
thank you for staying up with us
I am truly a masochist that is like the
cat of nine tails whipping myself
watching that ridiculous coverage so
that's that's gonna be the story seismic
stunning unbelievable the whole it's all
brand-new world huzzah has a you're near
that from the mainstream media
unfortunately a lot of Republicans are
taking this to heart and they're taking
away the wrong conclusions from this
race so let's go through the top seven
takeaways from Roy Moore's defeat in
Alabama what conservatives should really
learn number one no Roy Moore should not
have dropped out of this race after the
sexual impropriety allegations came out
they said there are a lot of Republicans
saying now I should have dropped out
there should have been a write-in
candidate against Doug Jones we could
have run Luther strange or mo Brooks or
somebody not true totally ridiculous
let's look at the timeline on November
9th that is when the first allegations
against Roy Moore came out keep in mind
these are 40 year old allegations but on
November 9th
we learned that there is a woman who
says that when she was 14
Roy Moore
sexually inappropriate with her see
sexually assaulted her and then a number
of other women came out and said oh yes
when I was 16 or 18 or 19 Roy Moore then
at the time 30 32 he got a little frisky
with me he too and it created this aura
of sexual harassment and sexual assault
those were the allegations these
allegations were conveniently timed you
notice you haven't heard about these
things for I don't know the 40 years
since they happened until just too late
for Roy Moore to get off that ballot so
people think it's very easy if Roy Moore
just dropped out
then they put someone else on the ballot
and the Republican would have won that
isn't true
according to Alabama state code you can
only remove yourself from the ballot 676
days before the election so if it's
after that time period you can't get off
of the ballot if more had dropped out
his name would still be on that ballot
he still would have the Republican line
some people also don't know when you're
running for office you need to get a
number of lines so for instance when I
would run campaigns in New York we try
to pick up the Republican line the
conservative line the Independence Party
line they're always doing the Democrats
would get working families party but you
get those lines and then the more lines
you have the better your chances of
winning if were wrong or had dropped out
and the Republican establishment or
Donald Trump even had endorsed someone
like Luther Strange who had lost in the
primaries or mo Brooks who didn't really
have much of a shot even though those
candidates would have been more likely
to win the general they would have had
to be a write-in campaign so there's a
very low chance that would have happened
I think Luther strangers polling it like
2% or something in a write-in campaign
in general election Roy Moore dropping
out would have guaranteed the seat would
have gone to a Democrat instead of what
we saw which was a tight race but you
know two or three points separating
these it was a clear outcome basically
but at least a close race dropping out
would have guaranteed it to Democrats
and I know what you're gonna hear you're
gonna hear well Lisa Murkowski the
senator from Alaska she won a write-in
campaign in 2010 it is completely
different she had a lot of things going
for her one she had enormous support
which Roy Moore
she was an incumbent she already had the
seat she or he had universal name
recognition she came from a political
legacy family she was widely known as
the heir to a political family and she
had a political right in campaign
campaign so her entire campaign was
about this right and she gave out
bracelets she instructed people on how
to spell her name it was just too late
there was a month till the election when
these allegations surfaced it couldn't
have happened added to all of this you
had Steve ban and inserting himself into
the Roy Moore campaign and playing it as
an anti establishment versus
establishment campaign so had Donald
Trump come out and endorsed the guy who
lost the Republican primary or someone
else it would have been seen widely as
opposing the will of voters opposing the
will of the populous and for a populist
president to do that it just can't
happen at the end of this election it
was a choice between Roy Moore and Doug
Jones anybody who's trying to tell you
otherwise is selling you a fantasy
number two no
the outcome is not stunning the
mainstream media will tell you it's
stunning it's unbelievable to hear them
tell it not since the Battle of Lepanto
has an underdog overcome so much to get
a victory
NBC News reported it's a stunning
victory Politico reported on the Alabama
earthquake the Washington Post democracy
dies in darkness called it miraculous
they're suggesting no one could have
ever predicted this this is a blowout
victory hmm
did anybody predict that Roy Moore would
lose the general let's cut to the tape
Luther will definitely win no you know
what I'm saying
Roy has a very good chance of not
winning in the general election it's all
about the general don't forget we don't
stop here you have an election coming up
the day this is over so this is over a
Tuesday on Wednesday morning the new
race begins you got to be a Democrat
Luthor's gonna win easily and Roy's
gonna have a hard time winning Oh Donald
Trump Donald Trump is the guy who
predicted this right the leader of Roy
Moore's party the Republican president
he predicted that Roy Moore would have a
very hard time he likely wouldn't win
the general election the mainstream
media are conveniently ignoring this
today because they need this to seem
like a seismic shift they need this to
show that all of the Republican momentum
all of the Trump momentum conservative
policy legislation like we haven't seen
in our lifetimes is coming to an end
they have to show that it stops that
Donald Trump predicted it during the
primary said yeah I don't know this guy
it's a tough it's gonna be a tough race
for him he isn't a great candidate he's
a flawed candidate this was before any
of the sexual allegations came out just
based on his appeal as a candidate
absent the dirty tricks absent people
coming out of the woodwork to accuse him
of things he knew it would be a tough
race this isn't stunning stop repeating
that number three Ronald Reagan's 11th
commandment now more than ever
Ronald Reagan was fine of saying there
is an 11th commandment we all must live
by thou shalt not speak ill of a fellow
Republican unfortunately many
Republicans were all too happy to jump
on the bandwagon against Roy Moore when
these accusations came out in part
perhaps because the going got a little
tough that's a that is a bad accusation
to say that a man in his 30s is creeping
on fourteen-year-old girls and so when
the going gets tough you want to run
away from that also I think people just
don't like more a lot of some
Republicans don't like him because of
his Trump eNOS something they don't like
him because he's a bible-thumper
they don't like him because he seems a
little slick a little unctuous whatever
do not speak ill of a fellow Republican
because by the way their this sexual
mania that took over the last days of
the Roy Moore campaign they had one
piece of solid evidence they had one
piece of solid evidence Gloria Allred
showed it off with that one accuser
during her big press conference it was a
yearbook that purported to have a
signature from Roy Moore saying sweet
things to the little girl we now know it
has been admitted that that evidence was
at least partially fabricated and they
hid that it was fabricated when they
showed it so the only hard evidence we
have is not credible and yet Republicans
were quick to throw Roy Moore under the
bus instead of saying nothing at all and
sort of spent stepping back a little bit
and saying well let's wait and see how
this plays out I'm not totally sure
because now there's a precedent which is
if you make allegations sexual
allegations in particular against a
Republican you will be assumed guilty
until proven innocent not a good way for
Republicans to move forward it really
damages us hopefully we'll learn not to
be so quick on the trigger in the future
number four Republicans need better
opposition research this is the part
where I talk about how the allegations
were pretty strong so these allegations
sure they were 40 years old but we know
from Moore's autobiography that he has a
thing for young teenage girls we know
from Moore's 2005 autobiography that he
met his current wife when she was a
teenager performing in a dance recital
he wrote quote I knew Kayla was going to
be a special person in my life and then
later when she was 23 I think they
connected and went on a date that's how
the story goes nevertheless he even
admitted that when she was a teenage
girl in a dance recital he had the eye
for her
so Roy Moore's opponents should have
known his Republican opponent should
have known this was a place ripe for
attack even if all of the allegations
were false they would be easy political
tricks to play they should have run
Moore's campaign should have protected
against that and Luther Strange's
campaign should have pounced on it if
these allegations are true they should
have found those people and they should
have made them make the claims during
the primaries so that strange would have
won and we would have a Republican in
the Senate from Alabama if they if those
claims weren't true Roy Moore should
have protected against that it means
that Luther strangers campaign was
confident I don't believe this was a big
conspiracy really by the establishment I
don't really buy that Mitch McConnell
knew about this and he was sitting on it
and hiding it I think if they had been
sitting on it they would have played it
in the primary they don't want to lose
that seat they could have easily bumped
out Roy Moore and given it to Luther
strange if this had come out Republican
voting was deeply depressed in the
general election
they easily could have defeated Roy
Moore in a primary and depressed his
supporters in that election but they
didn't do it I don't know if it's that
we're lazy because we've been running
against the Clintons who for whom every
scandal of the last three decades is
common public knowledge it's been
plastered all over TV for years and
years and years but you have to get
better at opposition research I place a
lot of the blame for this loss at Luther
strangers feet and at his campaign
because they didn't uncover this and
more didn't protect against it
number five do not OD on Kofi Kofi Fay
is a hell of a drug folks you've got to
use it sparingly and cautiously what I
mean by that there is a huge right-wing
exuberance more than I have ever seen in
my entire life a young life granted but
you know I've been on this earth a few
decades at least and we've never seen
anything like this wonderful
conservative legislation wonderful
executive priorities wonderful foreign
policy good judges being nominated
courts being stacked we're seeing
massive tax reform that we haven't seen
since Reagan but there is a limit there
is a limit you can't go crazy Donald
Trump has completely shaken up politics
he's radically altered what is
acceptable
specifically in political speech in
campaign speech in what a candidate
looks like he's cracked this political
correct
gross just the political language where
they say one thing and really you know
that they're lying but they're lying in
this way or they're lying in that way
Donald trunk he cracked that he cracked
the political correctness he cracked the
credibility of the mainstream media but
you can't get away with everything
he hasn't abolished the rules of
politics entirely Roy Moore did not have
a way forward he did not know how to
pivot his campaign
he gave this awful interview with Sean
Hannity let's hear it you know miss
Coffman do you know the mother I don't
know your scorpion from anybody I never
talked to her and they've had any
contact with her allegations of sexual
misconduct with her completely false I
believe they're politically motivated I
believe they're brought only to stop a
very successful campaign and that's what
they're doing
I've never known this woman or anything
with regard to the other girls you
understand this was 40 years ago she
said that you asked her out on the first
of several dates but nothing progressed
beyond kissing I don't remember specific
dates not do not and I don't remember if
it was that time or later but I do not
remember that but you know her but you
never dated her ever is that what you're
saying no her but I don't remember going
out on dates I knew her as a friend if
we did go out on dates and we did but I
do not remember that that is not an
answer so he's talking about two
different girls there but he's saying on
the one that's never happened this
fourteen-year-old girl it never happened
well did you date teenagers well no I
don't I don't remember specific dates
well did you date teenagers well you
know I that's not an answer
if you're gonna deny it deny it if
you're gonna own up to it own up to it
and explain it but move on pivot move on
the way that Roy Moore tried to pivot
was by blaming gays and lesbians and the
cultural left for harping on this sure
the cultural left might be harping on
this you're not going to be able to push
your campaign forward by trying to
scapegoat gays and lesbians when your
own sexual behavior is being called into
question you have to move forward Roy
Moore didn't do that he didn't have a
clear enough vision for his campaign and
he didn't have the courage or the
strength or the political smarts to
address the issue and move straight
forward plow right by it this brings us
to number six never defend never explain
always attack this is also from Ronald
Reagan Ronald Reagan would say if you're
explaining you're losing but Roy Moore
just kept on explaining he kept on
saying well I never
this forty years ago and even when I did
I got the mother's permission that
doesn't work pal when you do that you
you end up looking like Frank from
Always Sunny in Philadelphia I am NOT
gonna duel your kids I'm not like that
we got to definitely write a song about
how we do not diddle kids do not diddle
kids it's no good diddling kids there's
no quicker way for people to think that
you are diddling kids than by writing a
song about it you gotta race always just
says oh I wouldn't do it with anybody
younger than my daughter that could be a
documentary of Rome worst campaign that
is what it looked like when he came out
and ready to explain all of this don't
do that eventually he wised up and then
just denied it he called into question
some of the clearly the fabrication on
the yearbook signature but that's what
he looked like four weeks when these
allegations came out not a good look
there's no way to convince somebody that
you're not doing that when you're
constantly harping on these things and
going back and changing your story
slightly when Republicans were
confronted with various and sundry
allegations against Moore they would say
if you even support more you are a
pedophile there is a two-word answer
that they should have given Bob Menendez
Bob Menendez there is a sitting Democrat
United States Senator who federal
prosecutors think might have had sex
with underage prostitutes you don't hear
a peep about that you don't hear
Democrats calling on him to step down or
to resign the mainstream media have
blocked it out entirely because it
doesn't help out their narrative against
Republicans and against Roy Moore but
that's what they said the Democrats said
well if you vote for Moore you are a
pedophile and just to be precise about
language here what Roy Moore is accused
of is not pedophilia it the old Greek
word for this is if he Buffy Leah he's
accused of doing things weird sex stuff
with teenagers young teenage girls but
not with children there's a difference
between a six year old and a 16 year old
for instance
I guess you could make that point to
them but the real attack you have to
make is pushing forward pushing it back
on them say not only are your claims not
true not only is your evidence of the
yearbook which was fabricated not even
is that not credible but your own guy is
sitting in the United States Senate
accused of having sex with underage
prostitutes Senator Bob Menendez and
you're saying nothing on that and until
Democrats answer for that they have no
credibility on this issue and you don't
owe them one single explanation beyond
that political votes are when I vote for
somebody I do not suddenly take on all
of their moral characteristics that's
not how it works we live in reality and
in reality we have to elect people to
represent us on political issues in
legislative bodies
I do not become Chuck Schumer because
Chuck Schumer represents the state of
New York I do not become Kamala Harris
because Kamala Harris represents
California
I don't even become Donald Trump because
I voted for Donald Trump in the
presidential election I had I don't have
billions of dollars I don't have the
kind of crazy hair none that doesn't
happen because there are steps between
the representatives and their
constituents don't buy into that lie and
hammer them hammer them hammer them have
I made myself clear I hope so next and
final point do not get hypnotized this
one's really hard because the mainstream
media will do this to you according to a
report out from the media Research
Center today 91 percent of evening news
coverage about Donald Trump is negative
91 percent this is way higher than
previous presidents Republican or
Democrat there is wall-to-wall coverage
of all of the sex stuff with Roy Moore
and what's the refrain Roy Moore is a
pedophile Roy Moore is a pedophile
doesn't really analyze the evidence it
doesn't analyze what those words mean it
doesn't analyze what the accusations or
how many decades ago they took place but
do not be hypnotized I know you haven't
seen anything about Bob Menendez I know
all you've heard of that is what a mean
terrible rotten guy Roy Moore is but the
mainstream media or the communications
wing of the Democratic Party do not
believe what they're saying there have
been absurd retractions in just the last
few days from
CNN Washington Post the New York Times
they got stories completely wrong
important stories important stories
about so called collusion about the
White House about Donald Trump don't buy
what they are selling and don't buy
their premises because then you'll have
to arrive at their conclusions that
isn't true okay that's all I want to
talk about on how conservatives are
making wrong conclusions from this race
now we have to talk about the race
itself we have to bring on our lovely
panel of deplorable zaur all-female
panel the conservative millennial Ally
Stuckey and the Daily wires very on a
man to press to giacomo but first you
didn't I wasn't going to just give them
to you all willy-nilly without having to
talk to you first about man crates man
crates this is my favorite gift that
I've gotten thus far I've gotten it I
shouldn't be that blunt about it because
my fiancee did give me her Christmas
gifts already and she didn't give me a
man crate but man crate sent me one and
it's awesome
so man crates calm is the surest way to
find gifts that guys will actually love
guaranteed the one that I ordered is
from Andrew Clavin got the same one and
I was very envious of it so I begged
them to send me my own it's the whiskey
appreciation crate that has your name
inscribed on glasses and your initials
on and whiskey decanter and all sorts of
nuts and whiskey treats
there's the grillmaster crate with a
brass knuckle meat tenderizer and a
cast-iron smoker box yeah if you go to
man crates dot-com you can pick the
perfect crate and choose the delivery
date when the crate arrives how do you
open it with a crowbar of course with a
crowbar that has your name laser
engraved on it both men's health and
Allure magazine are saying man crates
are the perfect gift for men those two
magazines don't agree on anything they
have thousands of five-star reviews and
every man crate comes with a high-five
guarantee I think you're gonna love it I
think it will help you to own the
holidays they have over 100 hand curated
gift collections and by the way if you
don't want to get a personalized gift
like that you don't think that they'll
enjoy the whiskey collection or whatever
for some reason let's say you just want
to get a gift card very safe standard
gift get them a man crates dot-com gift
card
set and the gift card whichever gift
card you want will come in a block of
cement that yeah and with a sledgehammer
and you have to crack the cement in
order to get the gift card it's a lot of
fun
I think boring gifts aren't worth giving
if there is an experience that comes
with it if there isn't something fun and
personal and a story that will come out
of it
it misses half of the point so if you're
gonna give a gift if you're gonna give
your friends and loved ones Christmas
gifts give them one that comes with a
story and that you can laugh about for a
long time to come I'm getting mine in
the mail this week and I'm very excited
to use it so go to man crates dot-com
slash Knowles kayo wles you will get
five percent off of your order they
don't offer this discount anywhere else
that is five percent off at man crates
dot-com /ko wles man crates calm / keno
wles own the holidays okay ladies we
have to bring you on a tough night let's
begin
Allie what does this loss this new
Democrat in the Senate mean for tax
reform well unfortunately I don't think
it's a great set for tax reform I do
think the positive side about it
although you have already touched on
this so far is that we don't have such
an uphill PR battle now to fight of
course everyone who voted for president
Trump won and someone in the Senate that
would carry out president Trump's pro
America America first agenda and that
includes tax reform but I do think it's
a positive that we no longer have to
battle the media and battle the left and
defend ourselves as you explained we
would constantly be having to explain
ourselves by saying oh no we're not the
party of a sex offender or no we're not
the party of a guy who engages in
preying upon teenagers that's what how
we would be spending the next couple
years until until 2020 is explaining
that we are not the party of moremore
well now we don't have to waste our time
doing that we can actually focus on
maintaining the majority in the Senate
and then winning 2020 as well so I do
think it can be a positive and it does
take a real weapon out of their toolbox
absolutely I always advocate
explaining anything to them and saying
we don't owe you an explanation you have
Bob Menendez but you're right it does
make it much easier on the PR front and
it really was the worst night for Al
Franken al franken who think resigned a
couple weeks ago he now has to actually
resign and you know if Roy Moore had won
he could say well he they got more I'm
gonna stay but too bad now you're fired
sad sad I Donald Trump's catchphrase so
I suppose it's fitting Amanda what does
this mean for Republicans in 2018 well I
think I think we can just learn that
this was a really bad candidate like I
don't think this teaches us anything
else aside from Roy Moyer was a really
bad candidate and that's why I lost like
I don't think we can extrapolate from
this and think it's like a referendum on
Trump or anything like that I just think
we put not a good candidate forward I
mean mo Brooks would have wiped the
floor even though they're strange so it
was really and of course we can look to
Mitch McConnell and that was not the
best move on his part to try to rid
those other people from being in there
so maybe just take a look at our
leadership that would be a good move for
Republicans and then maybe that would
help us in 2018 he was a bad candidate I
do fear now that anybody can make up
allegations I'm not saying these
allegations are made up but anybody can
make them up especially if they're four
decades old and giving them a win on
this I just fear is going to unleash a
tidal wave of these allegations are we
gonna see this strategy played out in
2018 a 100% I've had reservations about
the whole me to campaign from the
beginning and this is and that's exactly
the right point is that anything can be
said Bill O'Reilly actually just
recently came out and he said that
there's a tape again I can't you know I
don't know if this is true or not but he
said that there's the tape of basically
an anti-trump attorney offering two
hundred thousand dollars to someone to
make up false sexual assault accusations
against President Trump to say that this
one never happened is absurd and we've
seen it in the past so it's it's a
really dangerous precedent again not to
say that the allegations against were
more were false we I don't know
some of them seem credible actually but
we could see this in the future where
you could you know tank a candidate
based off of allegations true or not
like I said we didn't even get to the
bottom of these and and the outcome of
that election was it was clear as day
that he wasn't gonna win because of the
allegations and really really dangerous
Chuck Schumer today reported to Capitol
Police that there was a plot afoot to
accuse him of sexual assault or sexual
harassment that that weren't true you
know it was just made up and cooked up
in some political operatives room I
thought well aren't we always supposed
to believe the women though what
happened to Chuck Schumer what happened
to woke Jack Alex well I think that I
think that's a really good point may
think the danger of Democrats employing
this kind of strategy going forward yes
it could be effective to taking down
Republicans but as they've seen it's
also effective in taking down Democrats
and so if they're willing to take down
their own side by taking down people
like Al Franken and John Conyers and
maybe even Chuck Schumer who knows not
starting that rumor but hey I'm not
starting that rumor that Chuck Schumer
is gonna get taken down by weird sex
time I'm sorry out there we do have to
believe a woman right so I think that
they have to be willing to turn that
sword on themselves if that's the sort
that they want to die on I think that
what they're doing is that they realize
that they're gonna take down some of
their own by spearheading this whole me
to movement and how they kind of
remedied that and how they kind of solve
that and is is by using Al Franken as
the guy who fell on his sword as the
scapegoat that said yes we're even going
to call out some of our own but when we
call out some of our own look what they
do they resign this is how whorl we are
we are willing to throw away some of her
own and stand for the principle of
morality our principle of against sexual
harassment which I don't think that's a
really moral stance at all I think it's
politically expedient but if they are
willing to continue to do that and
continue to allow their congressmen who
are accused of sexual assault to fall on
their swords then we're not gonna have
any Congress people anymore which I
think would
great didn't let the periods win yeah
well that's true although I am
sympathetic to Federalist 51 which says
that the Congress exists so that all the
sociopaths of the country can go into a
room and fight one another and the
Democrats they do seem to be much less
morally concerned much less morally
meticulous if you're the senator from
New Jersey named Bob Menendez but who
knows that's so strange
I do want to make just before we sign
off from Facebook and YouTube I do want
to point out we are not starting the
rumor that Chuck Schumer the senior
senator from New York and the Democratic
leader is a sexual predator we're not
starting that rumor so don't don't you
go around spreading that don't repeat it
that Chuck Schumer is a sexual predator
okay we've got a sign-off from Facebook
in YouTube if you already subscribe to
The Daily wire thank you very much it
helps us keep the lights on cough fa in
my cup it helps me recover on a horrible
terrible mornings like this when
Republicans lose Alabama so if you
haven't subscribed go to daily we're
calm right now what do you get
well it's $9 or $10 a month or $100 for
an annual membership you get me the
Andrew Clavin show the ben shapiro show
blah blah blah blah blah you get the
leftist tears tumblr now I will grant
you it's a little emptier this morning
after Doug Jones's victory last night
but look we got a lot more racist coming
folks we have a lot more winning the
house is moving very fast on tax reform
so it's really probably just a matter of
hours before this thing fills up again
and we can lower tax rates cut the
corporate tax and make America great
again so so go to Daley wire.com get
that leftist here's time alert right now
we will be right back
[Music]
okay in the news this one really rings
true for me a new study published in the
journal International psycho geriatrics
I could describe members of my family by
the way psycho geriatrics it shows that
the key to living a long life is being a
stubborn old Italian woman the common
personality traits that have helped a
group of ninety to one hundred and
one-year-old Italians is stubbornness
hope and a love for family and country
the lead author of the study went on
quote we also found that this group
tended to be domineering stubborn and
needed a sense of control which can be a
desirable trait as they are true to
their convictions and care less about
what others think get out of my
grandmother's house what are you doing
why are you recording there this is
almost an anti scientific study it seems
to me it's a scientific study that says
that instead of listening to scientists
you should just do what your Italian
grandmother says Ali how seriously
should we take this or any other
supposedly scientific psychological
study that promises us health and
happiness yeah I mean obviously I think
it's totally subjective and up to the
individual I like this I like anti
science science I think it's good
science I think it's completely
subjective how long people live I think
probably the biggest factor that I see
over and over again from scientists
psychologists alike is that stress is a
really big factor in how long people
live I mean I have a grandfather for
example who has smoked cigarettes and
has drank his entire life and is in no
way in good shape but he's lived a very
long time and then I have other people
in my family who have been the epitome
of great health and have suffered health
complications that had nothing to do
with how they lived their life but the
thing about my grandfather is is that he
has been virtually stress free he is
very content and who he is and in his
life he leads a very simple life and I
kind of think that's the common thread
that we see throughout people who end up
living a long time is kind of a lack of
stress which we have not picked the
right jobs I don't think she'll very
long lives that is try try to get my
requisite 14 hours of sleep a night but
been always just comes back
the door waking me up it's very
difficult hostile work environment
Amanda you are a future Italian
grandmother why is it that these traits
tend to lead to a long life I don't know
but this this is like the most
scientific thing because I'm basically
the person that they're describing oh
yeah I'm I think this is like 100
percent accurate I don't know I mean
it's it's I guess it can be subjective
like I was saying but I would like to
believe that this is 100% real so I will
live into a to 100 but like might might
not for example she's like 87 like Evan
of my family's lived to a very long life
maybe maybe there's like also guilt that
might also help someone live longer
that's like a good trait for Italian so
maybe made that too so do you want
that's the question that I posed this
panel of deplorable do you want to live
to a hundred years old
that's a hard one it depends if I can
still smoke stogies and have a little
Scotch in my glass then I think life is
still worth living you know I'll enjoy
the beautiful poetry of the world but my
my own grandmother if she if I set her
rage on the air she would she would come
through that wall and murder me so I'll
refrain from that she says it's 29 but
she still goes out she chases the deer
who eat her little flowers she chases
them with a hose around her property
this woman is tough as nails and yeah
there is something to living a long time
because you just refuse to let the world
kill you good luck yeah I don't know if
I would if I would want to do that I
don't know if it's if it's necessarily
the happiest you know 110 year old
person who's just stubborn and frowning
and angry at the world
but I do like that a love of country is
an aspect of this love of family and
love of country there's something about
enjoying the place that you are and the
people that surround you that doesn't
surprise me that they would want to
stick around it's very real it's very
tangible and it and you know it makes
life worth living
patriotism these tellers don't run if
you want to
a long time just love American we got to
move on Republicans plan to accuse the
Justice Department of bias
after newly revealed text messages among
FBI officials including some working on
the Muller probe revealed extreme
anti-trump bias and conspiracy last year
just before the election FBI agent Peter
struck I can't pronounce his name
Peter Stern doc texted FBI lawyer Lisa
Paige quote I want to believe the path
you threw out for consideration in
Andy's meat office meaning FBI director
Andrew McCabe that there's no way he
meaning Trump gets elected but I'm
afraid we can't take that risk it's like
an insurance policy in the unlikely
event you die before 40 ha ha ha that
text was sent just weeks after the FBI
investigation into Russian interference
began meaning that the whole
investigation appears to have begun as a
political hit job to damage Trump is
this a conspiracy Amanda is there a deep
state conspiracy against Donald Trump
I mean it's looking more like that a
notice from the saying that it was a
witch hunt and as the days pass it looks
more and more increasingly like it is in
which I mean these text messages it's
not just that they happen to you know
become a craft they happen to have a
political view that that would be kind
of expected
it's that text that you just read
where's the one almost like it was a
conspiracy like they were going to take
him down that is so so troubling and the
whole point of the special counsel of
his investigation is to read bias how in
the world is this rating bias I mean
Peter struck was just let go but I mean
he had his hands in everything
apparently he was like the only FBI
agent and he's a very severe fire so
it's like in the movies in the movies we
all picture it's just like one guy doing
everything that is Peter strode such a
joke yeah it's really bad if the texts
had just said trump what a jerk oh well
I don't like him that's one thing but
they're referring to meetings with the
director of the FBI on ways to take
Trump out very bad ally does the Mulder
there's no evidence of collusion so
that's also you know if we had some
evidence of collusion maybe we can be
like okay
like just get rid of that guy and
continue but where is the collusion well
there's collusion between the Justice
Department and the Hillary Clinton
campaign that's the collusion there's no
collusion between Trump and Russia Ali
does Muller who employed both of these
people in the text exchange who stacked
his investigation with people who are
against Donald Trump does Muller have
any credibility left does this
investigation have any credibility left
I don't think so and I used to be under
the camp that said okay we can't fire
Moeller that's gonna be an absolute
disaster but I think the more we learned
about the potential of the conspiracy
the more you really wonder if you should
be in this place not the very least do
we need to hire an investigation to
investigate the investigation I mean I I
think that's what the American people
deserve and I think it's crazy just how
much Trump continues to be vindicated in
this kind of thing I mean every time he
says some seemingly outlandish thing
about that there's no Russian collusion
and Obama wiretapped in and now the real
collusion is with Hillary Clinton and
the FBI and all this it seems ridiculous
at the time but it ends up that okay he
might not have worded it correctly but
he was actually right and I'm just
wondering if the FBI thought that they
were so savvy that this wasn't going to
come out at any point that they were
going to continue to spend this
narrative of collusion and then it
wasn't going to come back to bite it I
think it just kind of shows how stupid
they think the rest of the world is and
the rest of the American people are and
how stupid Trump and his cronies are
that they were never going to figure
something like this out and so I think
it's going to be amazing and amazingly
vindicating for all of us if at the end
of this there's obviously no Russian
collusion and the real collusion was
with the Hillary Clinton camp it'll just
be beautiful and that that hubris of the
FBI is so outrageous pride goeth before
destruction and a haughty spirit before
a fall you jerks we got you ha ha ha
next news story uh you know last week or
two weeks ago maybe I got in trouble
with lefties pretending to be offended
they weren't really offended but they
were pretending to be offended because I
suggested that the massive fire that
burned down Hollywood the one that
torched my commute and made me broadcast
from my apartment in front of my
Christmas tree that that was evidence of
God's unsubtle brushstroke you know
there the physical reflecting the
metaphysical the figurative in the sex
scandal melting down Hollywood and then
literally the same thing happening we
now know the immediate cause of the fire
that destroyed six homes and damaged two
dozen others
it was bums City officials have
confirmed the start the fire rather was
started by a cooking fire at a homeless
encampment LA mayor Eric Garcetti who
has completely failed to address the
homeless crisis passed the buck saying
quote you can never get to zero risk I
think it would be a mistake to think we
could all right Eric sure Amanda there
are homeless people camping out all over
the city why are there so many homeless
people yeah well that's the thing they
like instead of reflecting and being
like okay this is a massive homeless
problem let's address that maybe our
policies aren't so aren't doing so hot
we should change our economic policies
no no I think the solution that I read
and this is like legit is that they said
they wanted to educate the homeless
about these players like safety
precautions for the homeless like why
not try to make them not homeless but on
that on that point of the homeless
people it's true we need policies and
incentives so that they can't live like
bums for their lives but also that won't
solve it for everybody the poor will
always be with us
and in the 1980s we closed down a lot of
mental institutions during the Reagan
administration actually because there
were new psychotropic drug drugs that
would address psychological conditions
and then they would be better and these
people didn't need to be locked up
anymore trouble was they stopped taking
the drugs when they got out and all of a
sudden they were living in squalor again
we do not take mental health seriously
in the United States it's a touchy issue
because we don't want to be able to
commit people to institutions we want
them to be free to live lives of misery
and squalor and crime for themselves and
society but that isn't compassionate and
a huge proportion of homeless people
have mental illnesses so we ought to
take that seriously there's an there is
nothing compassionate
leftie politicians who think it's better
to leave them on the street than to get
them the care that they need even if
it's involuntary and the road to hell is
paved with good intentions
ladies that is all the time we're
actually running a little late it is
always so good to see you I was having
such a terrible morning I see you it
brightens my day my heart flutters my
calf FA rises through the roof thank you
very much the conservative millennial
Ally Stuckey The Daily wires on Amanda
presto Giacomo that is our show get your
mailbag questions in for tomorrow and I
will answer all of them and change your
lives hopefully for the better Andrew
Klavan changes them for the better I
think I either tread water or make them
a little bit worse but that's okay
that's fine anyway tune in tomorrow
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael nul show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017